so next game poem is called vector from
Germany as well let's see what we have
as an opening okay it doesn't move at
all rd six let's go e4 have you get a
fully door which also played quite a bit
of black let's let's try a different
setup oh it just takes I think Bishop f4
is the the move here but I don't know it
in detail of course and just I'm not not
a new four-player yeah it's a very
complicated line oh let's just hope he
doesn't know it okay not sure about this
move just wants to go 94
at a currency 794
looks really dangerous maybe I should
should just capture on d 594 queen d 4
wow this is a really problematic line to
face if you don't know at all what is
going on but you could just take on the
five of the night as well this doesn't
make any sense Wow hmm yeah I think I
have to go for this no idea hmm so what
now Queen 24 Bishop c5 I guess
the ship's e5 Queen takes d5 Bishop
takes f 2 wow I just I just can't
calculate this wow what what a simple
move to miss Wow oh well jeez Wow
Queenie 3d for Queen takes e4 this can
get very embarrassing quickly 23 Bishop
f5 loss most likely okay well okay you
really shouldn't go for this line if you
don't know at all what is going on of
course Queen d4 was ridiculous but
yes just lost I guess Bishop f5 form
he's got a ton of other interesting
tries Knight c3 bc then not then Bishop
f5 or take on c3 Queen f6 it's a an
abundance of nice attacking
continuations d4 as well take on new for
DC not sure what my move is then be
three you have this one
can I Castle 93 take on a five no idea
thats just lost anyway I guess
sticking their okay and take on at five
so now I could take on a a eight let's
try this okay push-up g5 in order to
take on f2 he's got f6 you should see
seven maybe
looks really bizarre he also has got
done between e7 tweenage for now at
least it's not an immediate immediate
mate I'm a pawn down and I've got no
time I got the bishop pair but that's
all now I should play Queen g5 I guess
we're changing it's ok as well it's an
extra porn but this looks some at least
playable ok I'm really glad to to get
the Queen's of here
okay let you let me off the hook a bit
it's it's still good for black of course
but still it's just just a point out it
looked like I lose the mouth set of
pieces at one point / time time problems
as usual but it's not not so quick as
well
this is almost compensation for the pawn
almost I guess I get a 4 6's hanging
so no I'm not even better I guess this
beep on should should be a problem for
him i guess i could just promote the
pond okay but it's winning anyway
check check check check check check
check black forfeits on time halt ok
this was completely losing in the
opening really amazing that I just I
just got out of this with a upon
important town I want to check this
quickly with the computer because it's
look it's looking completely lost okay
just just a quick check now the computer
simply wants to take d 5 with an
instance cough what 0.3 think that's
about equal okay Queenie for causes a
joke yeah 96 yeah he also wants to play
Bishop f5
now is giving g5s winning for black and
now g6 is an instant win it takes I need
to play Queen g5 then this is also
completely winning Queen edge for us
winning yeah had the suspicion during
the game as well + 84 + 88 points okay
Queen f2 rue period yeah this is just an
extra porn computer grease and then he
misplayed it to such an extent that a
really good compensation this already is
a position which white can fight yeah
this already this is all this is better
for white already yeah he just he just
missed the quick kill after the opening
and then he got really really problem
problems in this position interesting
yeah interesting game but you shouldn't
go for such sabra sharp lines without
knowing anything